des pompistes occupé en magasin et des
clients priés de se servir eux-mêmes
c'est ainsi depuis début décembre ces
salariés prennent leur mal en patience
avant la concrétisation d'un projet de
mise en sécurité de cet espace
lors d'une réunion datant du 12 décembre
une proposition a été soumise et un
accord a été trouvé entre toutes les
parties
d'après ce plan un radar fixe sera
positionné sur l'autoroute et l'accès
actuel supprimer la ctm a écrit au
propriétaire de la station où le
suggérer une solution d'accès à partir
lui louvroil qui dessert l'aérogare mais
pourquoi cela se fasse il faut d'abord
l'accord la yoda deuxièmement comme ça
se fait un domaine privé nous avons
proposé un partage des frais la partie
publique où nous allons fermer l'accès
actuel et il met une glissière de
sécurité sur la prise en charge par la
cité m mais la partie polluée
le nouvel accès nord globaux des
obligataires le bon d'achat
un coût estimé à 138 milles euros qui
sera financée par la ctm hauteur de 20 %
le reste étant à la charge du
propriétaire soit 80% de la somme
globale mais une convention devrait être
signée de cofinancement entre la station
vito la propriété de sociétés au rugby
et la cdm pour monter le financement une
solution mais dans combien de temps
et qu'en pensent les principaux
concernés c'est pas le salarié
ça sera le conducteur qui descend et qui
se fait ou que sais je dirais même qu'il
était temps il était grand temps que ça
se fasse
passion vous même ben oui pour sécuriser
tout le monde et puis pour moi c'est une
bonne chose
la concrétisation on a effectivement eu
des mots mais on attend la
concrétisation
on peut pas tirer de plans sur la comète
parce que on a tendance en virage
jusqu'à quand est ce qu'ils feront les
travaux
une lueur d'espoir pour un personnel
durablement marquée par des accidents à
répétition depuis deux ans un personnel
qui constate par ailleurs une baisse
significative de la fréquentation du
site